you see you see logan paul moving to
puerto rico
oh he's doing that yeah today he's
moving to puerto rico
to evade texas i know he said it i
watched i was like watching the
clip from his podcast he was like yeah
i'm just moving for taxes honestly
and then he was like plus boxing and i
want to be away from everything everyone
in miami wants to drink and do drugs and
i'm like focus on my boxing so i got to
do training camp for a couple months and
get my
i can't do anything like that so i'm
going to go to puerto rico but
it's just like i don't know i don't
understand why like because it hit and
everyone's like
man this is too hard we shouldn't have
to pay taxes too
yeah like why wasn't tax evasion a thing
before
like no one everyone was like we're
moving to la we're just going to pay the
13
state tax because california's cool and
now it's like
that shit's messed up dude 13 it's not
fair
because in puerto rico where it's four
percent
13 was worth it when you could flex on
everybody
when you can invite people over to your
[ __ ] and you know drive your car
to go you know your dope-ass car go buy
a stupid-ass bagel or something and
yeah you know just try to try to fly but
now you can't flex
because what's the biggest flex right
the biggest flexes be on the internet
look at me evading taxes
yeah [ __ ] losers
that's the that's got to be the way i
mean
do they even is puerto rico of like
fiber
like internet uh yeah
definitely i think uh
but it's [ __ ] far away and yeah
here's the thing though i was looking it
up because i was like i wonder because i
hear all the time right old dudes buying
houses in puerto rico
to evade taxes i'm like how many how
much taxes are there there it's four
percent
that's it like total like federal no
state tax that's [ __ ] insane
it's it's so i'm like i'm
watching this thing i'm like this is so
stupid like you're like just moving away
we should move and then i'm like i'm
googling them four percent
maybe we should take a trip just to like
see we should all we should all move
everyone into the podcast just go test
the waters a little bit let's just go
dip our toes in and see what it's like
there
and then i'm looking at real estate i'm
like searching luxury real estate
just to know like what what like you
know the ultra high end
is i mean it's still a lot like you're
paying like
like you pay like six million bucks and
you're getting like but like um
like like insane house
well i won't look this up right now
luxury real estate
puerto rico yeah i wanted to know like
what the high
high you know you go to these like the
houses like on like the golf courses and
[ __ ] like that yeah
yeah like in how in you know hawaii
these would cost like 25 million bucks
what does it cost in puerto rico i'm
just right
right yeah
this is crazy yeah yeah this is [ __ ]
crazy
yep yeah right here let me pull
something up right here
this is crazy luxury
helipad state wow
yeah [ __ ] sid isn't it isn't this a
fun thing to do um
yeah y'all want to move
we're gonna we're gonna buy a big-ass
house and rent out rooms to
podcast listeners just like that other
place
we shot the tarot card reading it blue
can you
let me share my screen real fast
damn damn dude
all right what kind of natural disasters
happen to puerto rico though cause like
island [ __ ]
like
look at this [ __ ] this is on the ritz
carlton reserve i don't know how much
this is it's probably like
10 million but look at 13 000 square
feet yeah that's
i mean i guess you could find a house
like this anywhere but
you could but what's the price though
it doesn't say on that one probably
dummy expensive what else we got
look at this one 4 300 square feet 3.9
million bucks
it's like on the beach yeah that's it
just is this
yep just sell all your personal
just sell everything your kidney
everything
yeah i'm getting all right dude i love
real estate porn
yeah you know you know just unattainable
[ __ ] you know okay so there's a
hurricane
maria it uh
yep it hit in 2017.
this thing killed 3000 people jeez
the deadliest the deadliest us-based
natural disaster in a hundred years
wow yeah see worth it though for those
taxes
you know i attempt that i
you know i'd risk it why not
i mean yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's a pretty wild move
i mean should we even get this new
studio should we just like put it on
pause and just
i'll go to puerto rico
it kind of feels like people are just
scrambling they're like everyone's
leaving so i gotta do it too
yeah yeah and everyone's like yeah this
la chapter's over man you can just feel
it things are ending here
you know it's kind of you know it's
gonna suck for everybody what when uh
when all like these executives and stuff
get vaccinated and they're like i'm just
going back to my home in cali
yeah then everyone that moved to these
other cities are like
wait i i thought it was yeah nah
nah i kept my place back there you know
just in case yeah
you know they got the office for me over
there so you know and my mom's over
there so i think i'm
just gonna head back and uh yeah
yeah actually no you know it's you know
here's the grim thought all right this
is dark as [ __ ]
every executive right now went to their
hometown
you know to like live with their old
people
and then you know what
oh wow that's not you know
and then they go
[Music]
and take that inheritance and yeah
move back thanks my pain thirteen
percent got all this
new money i got so much back
flip back i love you me ma let's see you
guys
big rp i'm putting five resistance on
for you put fire resistance on for your
grandma
don't worry when i buy this peloton with
that with that inheritance money just
give me i'll put my resistance on for
you
i don't think you have you bae i'm
talking to you mimo
does it get jacked honestly grandma
might have to make it seven resistance
because
all this money is like literally
weighing me down
so i'll be used to it by the time i get
that peloton
my pockets are overweight now
gotta work that off love you
love you gramps it's [ __ ] crazy being
a billionaire and hot
it's crazy having a billion dollars and
being [ __ ] sexy
if you are riding for your newfound
inheritance please add five resistance
right now folks
people are snitches dude we talked about
that in the bonus episode and then
we cut that tick tock clip out of that
yeah and everyone's like you did the
post malone ride that's ali loves ride
oh that's ali love tagging her
i'm a fan of her and i'm a fan of the
class i can talk a little [ __ ] about it
today oh my god the dude i was with the
dude i was
riding with my coach today oh what did
he say it was so
[ __ ] funny
oh man sometimes you just you'll just
start talking because they have to fill
space and they'll go yeah that's a story
for another time
[Laughter]
don't laugh like that because no one
else in the studio
you when you laugh by yourself like it's
not real you gotta super
exaggerate it yeah oh man it's so funny
just thinking about that just
twitch streaming on a peloton yeah
in a big ass studio one camera guy
thank you for the bits
that's the story for another time
[Laughter]
at five resistance let's go bro
i looked up i'm looking up a little bro
i'm looking up billy billionaires list
i'm trying to see who's the hottest
billionaire
my which billionaire is my guy no come
on man let's look at this billionaire
list
i want to see the billionaire baddies yo
is that
that is that a instagram account
billionaire baddies hold on
yes it is yes it is really yeah
billionaire
nah these aren't billionaires man these
are just
these are just baddies what the [ __ ] no
these are just
random women these are just millionaire
baddies
[Laughter]
we need billionaire billionaire baddies
that's good
they have to be actual billionaires who
is the hottest billionaire
well
[Music]
jeff bezos has 192 billion dollars
that's
so [ __ ] stupid look at this top 15
sexiest billionaires on men's xp.com
yeah i can't believe this is real you
know you know ugly
i'm looking at all right so i'm looking
at this list
and the first woman shows up at rank 13.
francois betancourt meyers and family
she's french okay alice walton
go ahead sergey brin co-founder of
google this guy
is a four
no shade so am i but straight up this is
not a sexy man
mark zuckerberg is number 15 on this
list get the [ __ ] out of here
get the actual [ __ ] out of here
you